I actually was a huge superfan when you
were on American Idol I still am a fan
but I I remember I know I'm not alone
it's like the most obvious thing
everybody was obsessed with you and
continues to be but I I was supposed to
go to the finale and I had tickets and I
was so excited and I was working on that
show 24 and I got a call time that went
too late and I missed it and I'm still
doing
we hate 24 I love 24 I'm just kidding
but yeah so look it's like I ain't know
anything I just look like a total boob
and cry it was so dumb I I cry I've
asked anyone I cry - I watched it
crasher was I was literally you know I
was crying so hard yes trees were being
made but also is like I never have to
serve another drink to a drunk guy again
during the talk I mean after ten years
of doing the talk like how is it you
just recently went back how was it it
felt like home you know when you go back
to something you've been out for so long
and I was so excited to go back and see
everybody and I actually felt more sad
in a way leaving because it went so fast
yeah like I was just there for a couple
hours in my mind I had built up like I'm
going back I'm going back and going back
and then I was like oh it's it's over
yeah no oh my gosh that it must been a
trip though that's a long time to be on
a show like you create that family it's
a long time in a long time and I'll just
keep finding excuses to go back I love
the group group
I agree so what is it like filming the
Connors now if like is it like 30 years
yes it was only cuz I grew up with you
like I can't believe I'm sitting next to
you like I always get three people that
work constantly in your life like every
day like it's known as those kind of
stars that always kind of I get
starstruck with because I'm like wait
you were here I was with you like every
day like when you grew up on TV yeah I
like real that with people you grow up
with that feels so not like in a very
safe way yeah it's incredible for me to
to be with these people that I've known
my whole life and have this history with
and do these scenes together that have
so much built into them it must be an
amazing thing to be a part of something
that was so rare like I feel like
Roseanne like friends like there's these
mash I think those shows that kind of
stick out in time there's others I'm
forgetting but I just mean that the cast
is so perfect the chemistry is so
perfect whatever goes into play is just
perfect and I love that like 30 years
later y'all are doing it again and
you're down you can't you just you just
never know when you put a group of
people together how it's gonna work and
it's just part of it is luck then you
have the chemistry and the relationships
yeah and just to be a kid and Hollywood
that must been hard growing up on the
show so it's good you had it was like a
family environment that's kind of cool
yeah very cool it's fun you're doing it
again you're doing second season and
also executive producer right I am so
you're acting your executive or your mom
do you want another job
it's funny because I left I left to talk
so I would have a little more time and
then this morning I had a few hours
because I was coming here so I pushed my
work day got pushed later and I
literally didn't know what to do I was
like I need another jobs no call time
there's no schedule yeah I panic like
because I'm so busy all the time I'm
with you it's like wait nobody's telling
me when to eat or like what to wear or
yeah I think she's better when I have
structure but you have more time for
your family though now that you're not
doing that and you're just doing the
Conners I do and I get to pick up my
kids sometimes or take them to school or
do they come on set ever they do come on
set they say they're coming to see me
but I have a lot of evidence to the
contrary so they'll come when I do the
Conners and they'll run around with all
the other kids and they say they're
watching the show and then when I asked
they have like no idea what the plot was
and then when I did the talk they'd
always say like oh well what are the
giveaways today you'll see me like no no
we're coming to see you and then all of
a sudden I go right then I go into like
one of my kids rooms and there's like a
new TV and a vacuum cleaner I'm like
thanks for getting it order it and I
really there's like 14 blenders in my
living room
that's my kids do that we have we all
have kids at the voice and there's like
a little like compound there and they
always say they're coming for me but
really they're coming for the sugar
that's a catering oh yeah and the
children
yeah even carry that I'm their food is a
bag the food is a big attraction
what is it yet well then my food at my
house is like no fun so yeah they don't
like me either weekend's I give them
weekends yeah they hate me yeah I don't
care I'm like ghost of Christmas future
you don't have to work like it's like
I'm trying to help you I'm trying to
help you I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this